bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
du vendredi nous sommes le 29 janvier
voici les principaux titres dans le
cadre de la concertation préalable à la
création de la zone d'aménagement
concerté et de versailles satory ouest
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris-saclay vient d'organiser un
après-midi de séminaires ouverts à tous
les publics
elle nous verrons que le jeu vidéo a
toujours le vent en poupe avec
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle formation sur
saint quentin en yvelines l'inauguration
a eu lieu en présence d'une joueuse
professionnelle et puis comme chaque fin
de semaine nous revenons aussi sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité depuis lundi
mobilisation des taxis des enseignants
ou encore future élection pour la
succession de valérie pécresse au poste
de député des yvelines dans la 2e
circonscription
les cérémonies de voeux se poursuivre
pour les élus et hier soir jeudi c'était
au tour de benoît hamon député des
yvelines conseiller régional il a
notamment annoncé quelques projets
locaux qu'il appuiera en tant qu'élu
nationale l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 et l'aménagement du
carrefour de la mer me donne il ya un
engagement de la région ile-de-france
qui j'espère sera confirmée par valérie
pécresse un engagement de l'état
une volonté du département de soutenir
ce projet
pour donc permettre
de faire un plateau urbain au dessus de
la nationale 10 et donc éviter toutes
les nuisances aujourd'hui qui sont
celles de la nationale 10 le second
c'est le commissariat d'elancourt l'état
des faits une étude de faisabilité est
disponible pour cofinancer le projet le
troisième dossier c'est celui du
la fibre optique à fontenay le fleury
est
qui m
un projet important c'est important pour
fontenay qui on a besoin aujourd'hui
pour rentabiliser d'autres
investissements qu'il a fait notamment
en termes d'équipement numérique des
écoles lors de son discours de voeux le
député à a précisé aussi qu'il voterait
contre le projet de loi gouvernemental
sur la déchéance de la nationalité la
loi sera soumise au vote des députés à
l'assemblée nationale à partir du 5
février
moi je ne veux pas que la déchéance de
nationalité ceux réservés aux
binationaux comme on peut pas le faire à
tous les français je pense qu'il faut
une peine symbolique c'est
peine symbolique ça peut être une peine
la dignité nationale qui prive de ses
droits civiques et droits familiaux
celui qui a retourné ses armes contre la
nation c'est nécessité pas d'introduire
une différence entre citoyens français
inscrits dans la constitution
voilà je trouve que ce débat a créé de
la discorde là où il faudrait de la
concorde
benoît hamon au micro de mélanie poquet
le président de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie versailles yvelines s'est
lui exprimé dans le cadre de sa
cérémonie de voeux jeudi soir il a
rappelé son ambition d'aider au
développement les entreprises du
territoire
et côté projets a souligné en 2016 la
création d'un cluster aéronautique à
toussus-le-noble autour de l'aviation du
futur ou encore le développement
touristique du secteur du mantois autour
à des riffs de scène cantat à 2015
l'année restera à celle du lancement des
réunions thématiques autour du
développement à l'international et de
l'économie circulaire on nous animons
actuellement n 1 us industriels sur
l'automobile est aussi nous accompagnons
les collectivités du territoire de la
vallée de seine pour un projet
touristique sur la vallée de seine
donc ça ces deux projets pour nous très
important mais nous allons mettre en
place surtout un projet qui s'appelle
open in off qui permet justement
d'animer d'animer l'innovation dans les
yvelines et c'est un projet pour nous
très important parce que l'on pense
qu'il faut vraiment avoir une structure
d'animation de l'innovation dans les
yvelines
propos recueillis par fanny bourdillon
quelle vision et quelles ambitions pour
le quartier versailles satory ouest
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris-saclay vient de proposer à un
séminaire ouvert à tous avant que ne
s'ouvre la concertation autour de la
création de la zone d'aménagement
concertée sur ce secteur enjeux
économiques architecture au coeur des
débats
le nouveau quartier de versailles satory
ouest ne devrait pas voir le jour avant
mais déjà des préoccupations sont au
coeur du projet associations et
habitants les ont exprimé ce jeudi lors
de séminaires à la mairie de versailles
satory donnant directement sur la bièvre
c'est un projet qui
qui nous concerne directement à partir
du moment où il ya des projets notamment
des projets immobiliers
on est forcément un petit peu sur sur la
défensive et on souhaiterait en savoir
davantage sur les perspectives qui ce
quartier de versailles considéré comme
le huitième veux être un modèle en
termes de développement durable et de
respect de la nature sur l'ambition en
termes de développement durable ville
durable
c'est un enjeu fort que l'on souhaite
développer surtout les tous les projets
de ce grand cluster d'innovation qui est
le territoire de paris saclay versailles
et c'est dans cette démarche là qu'on
est là pour présenter aussi l'ensemble
des partenaires qui seront là elle est
maître d'oeuvre sont là située au
sud-ouest de versailles le quartier de
satory possède actuellement de nombreux
atouts qu'il sera impératif de
sauvegarde et nous insistons beaucoup
sur le fait que c'est un cadre qui a une
qualité végétal assez exceptionnelle
puisqu'on est au dessus d'un plateau et
que deux autour de ce plateau vous avez
des bois qui sont vraiment de qualité
d'un côté la balle et la bière et à
l'autre côté des vues directement sur
jardins du château de versailles
donc il est très important de l'assuré à
la population ou amoureux d'art cinq son
nombre que l'on maintienne cette qualité
quasi historique du site
la préoccupation numéro un du maire de
versailles reste la desserte de la ville
par les transports la ligne 18 du métro
du grand paris devrait passer par la
gare de versailles chantiers et du
plateau de satory un tout autre sujet à
présent une formation jeu vidéo verra
bien le jour à l'école d'audiovisuel et
d'animation troisième à saint quentin en
yvelines et cette formation devrait
plaire aux générations de jeunes joueurs
qui sont nés avec un joystick à la main
avec le développement des jeux en
application la demande des entreprises
est forte pour l'occasion elle c'est
l'artiste électronique kayane qui a eu
l'honneur d'inaugurer à cette filière
qui sera également couplé à un studio de
motion capture fanny bourdon étudier les
jeux vidéo
un rêve pour de nombreux gamers et c'est
l'école d'animation troisième à
elancourt qui proposera une filière jeu
vidéo à la rentrée prochaine un cursus
en cinq ans qui devrait former les
développeurs de demain
avant que c'est important qu'il y ait ce
genre de formation en france déjà pour
former peut-être à futures élites qui
vont créer les jeux vidéo
merger de demain pourquoi pas des
nouveau rayman on sait pas pour
l'inauguration de la filière la joueuse
professionnelle kayane a tenu une
conférence la jeune femme animatrice
également sur game one est heureuse de
pouvoir milité pour la reconnaissance du
jeu vidéo
ça montre qu'il ya des écoles et donc
des personnes derrière qui croient aux
jeux vidéo à son avenir qui croient que
la france a un fort potentiel là dedans
et
ça nous change des discours qu'on peut
voir à la télé ou de personnalités qui
pensent que le jeu vidéo c'est le mal
absolu
ça nous donne aussi la possibilité pour
des gens qui sont passionnés par les
jeux vidéo de d'avoir l'espoir et la
possibilité d'en faire un métier de
travailler dans ce secteur là l'école a
aussi inauguré son studio de motion
capture
un équipement indispensable pour la
création des personnages et des décors
de jeux vidéo le studio de motion
capture c'est un vrai pari sur les
innovations technologiques de l'école
l'idée par rapport à ce studio c'est de
créer un véritable avantage on va dire
concurrentiel par rapport à d'autres
écoles qui ne peuvent pas s'équiper d'un
tel d'un tel matériel la motion capture
ça permet comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure
d'animer des personnages fictifs avec
des mouvements humains le plus réaliste
possible
et c'est demain l'avenir des jeux vidéo
de l'animation
cette formation pourra accueillir
jusqu'à 40 étudiants sortants du bac 2
profils sont actuellement recherchés des
game designers pour la conception du
scénario des jeux et des profils de game
art pour la réalisation artistique
nous passons à l'essentiel de
l'actualité de la semaine le zapping de
la faune locale depuis lundi et puis
juste après un retour sur la
mobilisation enseignante de mardi 40
voix pour et deux abstentions les
conseillers départementaux ont voté la
hausse du taux de la taxe foncière sur
les propriétés bâties passé de 7 58% à
12 58 une hausse de 66% représente en
moyenne 125 euros par foyer
une décision justifiée par un budget de
combat selon le président du département
liés à des baisses importantes des
dotations de l'état dans le département
y en a vraiment ras le bol
on est tous comme tout comme paris les
fédérations toutes les fédérations
nationales on est tous d'accord pour
dire que c'est bon quoi maintenant ça
suffit les textes ne sont pas respectées
nos licences on les a payées on a payé
des impôts dessus
donc aujourd'hui on n'a vraiment plus
rien à perdre cette année l'armée a
enregistré une augmentation des
candidats sur un territoire par rapport
à 2014 conséquences des attentats de
2015 sur ce salon depuis maintenant
plusieurs années on constate un taux de
fréquentation très très fort pour
l'instant on est sur une orientation
andrew de 20 à 25 % de taux très
cotation supplémentaire petit commence
sans diplôme bac + 5
l armée attire tous les profils goût de
l'aventuré ou envie de servir son pays
les motivations sont diverses alerter
masser défibriller posé un garrot et
traiter les hémorragies ces gestes qui
peuvent paraître complexes au premier
abord seront dispensés au cours de
sessions de formation gratuite sur tout
le territoire yvelinois dès le 1er
février
ensuite du mardi noir parmi les
grévistes aujourd'hui les enseignants
étaient eux aussi mobilisé leurs
principales revendications les salaires
et le pouvoir d'achat
ils demandent notamment la fin du gel du
barème des salaires sur le département
la mobilisation a été de 15,19 % dans le
primaire et le secondaire
l'islam est d'abord se confond les gens
et c'est très important l'islam ce sont
des textes à travers une histoire à
travers des interprétations et puis les
gens puisent dans ces textes là des
éléments pour leur idéologie et moi mon
travail c'est d'essayer de le ramener à
savoir une méthodologie pour essayer de
s'inscrire véritablement dans l'histoire
période izel et qu'un siècle qui
séparait l'islam d'aujourd'hui à ses
fondements et l enjeu de la rencontre de
lundi 25 janvier organisée à trappes par
le collectif parole à coeur ouvert
je pense que
député maire de vélizy c'est c'est un
poste passionnant où et je pense que je
fais tous les jours aussi bien quand je
suis en contact les quatre grands chefs
d'entreprises qui sont ici ou avec mes
citoyens
finalement il ya on s'aperçoit que la
vraie vie aller sur le terrain et qui a
beaucoup de mesures législatives à faire
évoluer puis ça me permettra aussi
d'avoir un député un peu différent qui
viennent du monde de l'entreprise et
nous citoyens vient d'élire son nouveau
président en son nom nicolas doucerain
une élection avec à 59,5 % des suffrages
exprimés pour cet entrepreneur de 39 ans
qui veut conserver l idée d'origine et
tourner rapidement la page jean marie
cavada
l'eurodéputé avait pris la tête du
mouvement provisoirement pendant
quelques mois fin 2014
avant de claquer la porte en dénonçant
un manque de démocratie interne voisins
le bretonneux entre dans une nouvelle
ère celle de la fibre optique et la
commune s'équipe pour fournir à ses
habitants internet en très haut débit
retour sur l'opération qui doit débuter
avant cet été la 39 millions d'albums
vendus
ça représente 450 9 millions d'euros en
2015 plus de 5000 livres ont été publiés
dont 3924 sont de strictes nouveautés il
y en a pour tous les goûts la bd
jeunesse la bd historique
l'éternel bd franco-belge et celle pour
adultes qui prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur de l'édition les obsèques de
michel tournier décédé lundi 18 janvier
à l'âge de 91 ans lieu cet après midi à
l'église de choisel dans les yvelines
le bâtiment est situé à côté du
presbytère dans lequel il résidait une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
pour lui rendre hommage aujourd'hui ses
amis sa famille mais aussi les habitants
de la commune et quelques personnalités
littéraires comme bernard pivot était
invité la cuisine gastronomique
nécessite exigences et rigueur les
journées démarrent à 8 heures pour la
mise en place et se termine à une heure
du matin à la fin du service
vous aviez pincemin dirige une brigade
de douze cuisiniers une expérience
qualifiante qui a donné envie à son chef
simonet zanoni de l'inscrire au concours
top chef
quand j'ai appris qu'il m'avait inscrit
ce match et je me suis dit la confiance
en moi et ça m'a fait plaisir
mehdi bon moi j'ai pas fait sept ans de
travail avec avec ce chef là pour rien
c'est que voilà il ya quand même une
certaine reconnaissance
c'est vrai que ces mots n'est pas un
chef qui va t'applaudir qui va te dire
ouais bravo super ce que tu as fait et
je reçois je dis aujourd'hui pour
revenir sur l'actualité bertrand mesures
dont soir vous êtes cette semaine nous
étions grève en tant que secrétaire
départemental fsu et ses nuits effet 78
les enseignants qui sont mobilisés une
nouvelle fois avant même de parler des
raisons peut-être le bilan déjà de
l'action selon l'académie de versailles
le taux d'enseignants en grève
environ 14% dans le premier alors déjà
c'est comme d'habitude le ministère des
méthodes de comptage qui ne permettent
pas de recenser l'ensemble des
enseignants je pense qu'on était plus de
près de 20 25 puisqu'il ya une partie
des personnes qui ne sont pas décomptés
dans les chiffres que fournit le
ministère qu'est ce qui n'est pas
décompté par exemple tous les
enseignants du premier degré qui ne ce
qu'ils ne vont pas être remplacé le jour
même comme par exemple les enseignants
en réseau les directeurs des charges et
s'ils sont en grève ne sont pas
décomptés dans le second degré le
décompte effet le matin à 8 heures et
tous les enseignants qui arrive après à
9 heures ou à 10 heures pour faire leurs
cours ce ne sont même pas considéré par
ses des comptages pour la précision sur
les chiffres au delà de ça vous nous
disiez autour de 20% en tout cas c'est
vraiment retenir assez suffisant pour
vous c'est suffisant c'est une grève
fonction publique je pense que il est
important que un nombre significatif de
collègues se saisissent de cette
problématique du salaire qui commencent
à impacter très lourdement la fonction
publique et les enseignants en
particulier
c'est la principale revendication
salaires pouvoir d'achat à la fin du gel
du barème des salaires le seul à gel du
point d'indicé et plus généralement un
rattrapage par rapport à ce que là ce
qui devrait correspondre aux
qualifications qui sont celles des
enseignants ou celle des personnels de
la fonction publique j'ajouterai que
cette grève était aussi celle de mes
collègues du second degré qui
souhaitaient s'opposer et continuer à
s'opposer à la réforme du collège qui
malgré les aménagements qui a mis en
place le ministère n'est toujours pas
satisfaisant on va parler on va
s'attarder un petit peu effectivement
sur la réforme des collèges auparavant
sur la question du salaire concrètement
si on part le chiffre ça représente quoi
ce gel depuis combien de temps qu'elle
signe de pouvoir la gestion
si on reprend ce que ça représente c'est
à dire que le gel du point d'indicé
représente à peu près deux mois de
salaire depuis les années 2000 c'est à
dire entre le retard qu'ils avaient été
pris à partir des années 2000 et le gel
depuis six ans ça représente à peu près
deux mois de salaire ce qu'il faudrait
si on voulait rattraper ce retard
concrètement du jour au lendemain ça
après je sais pas ce qu'il faudrait si
on fait des comparaisons avec les pays
européens là je sais qu'on ce n'est très
en retard on est parmi les derniers pays
d'europe et de l' ocde en termes de
salaires des enseignants et après ça
dépend où on met le curseur
mais en tout cas c'est pas à la hauteur
des qualifications des master 2 est ce
que vous demandez aujourd'hui comme ça
déjà c'est d'avoir que le principe du
dégel du point d'indicé soit actée et
qu' ils commencent à récupérer ce qui a
été perdu les années précédentes
si on vous explique une nouvelle fois
qu'il faut faire des économies que les
caisses sont vides alors si on
m'explique on a des arguments il ya déjà
plein de façons de récupérer de l'argent
ne serait ce qu'en s'attaquant à la
fraude fiscale ne serait ce qu'en
s'attaquant à la défiscalisation que met
en place les grandes entreprises pour
échapper à l'impôt sur le territoire
donc il ya des ressources il suffit
d'aller les chercher et de ne pas être
en permanence à l'écouté de ceux qui
disent qu'on a pas les moyens
on peut parler aussi de cette réforme du
collège vous l'avez dit réforme qui qui
passe mal qu'est ce qu'il bloque dans
cette réforme collège 2016 à
l'enseignement pratique
interdisciplinaire par exemple alors en
fait ce qui passe mal au niveau des
enseignants en pratique
interdisciplinaire c'est la très grande
difficulté qu'il y allait mettre en
place c'est à dire qu'on a supprimé des
horaires d'enseignement dit enfin des
horaires d'enseignement
comment dirais-je de matière pour mettre
en place ces enseignements
interdisciplinaire pour ça pour croiser
les matières c'est pour croiser la
matière mais après le problème c'est que
sur le terrain ça devient extrêmement
compliqué à organiser
j'en discutais il ya peu de temps avec
avec un collègue qui était chef
d'établissement apparemment les chefs
d'établissement sont en train de faire
des pieds et des mains pour aller au
lycée parce que la mise en oeuvre sur le
plan du collège est extrêmement
compliqué c'est la quatrième fois sur ce
sujet de réforme des collèges que
l'intersyndicale a appelé à une grève et
mai juin septembre 2015 la participation
est pas toujours et en tout cas en
baisse depuis le
mais la première mobilisation de demain
vos collègues dans collège vont
continuer le mouvement écoute et qu'on
avait appris que le gouvernement
n'allait pas lâcher
alors le gouvernement a déjà lâché sur
un certain nombre de points puisqu'il a
réintroduit les classes bilangues il a
réintroduit un certain nombre de choses
maintenant sonné on rentre dans le dur
si je puis dire de la réforme c'est à
dire la faisabilité pratique et c'est là
que justement les choses commencent à
coincer partout et on verra en cours
d'année si la mobilisation s'amplifie
mais en tout cas le la qualité qui était
annoncée n'est pas vendu il ya aussi la
question de l'autonomie ce que
maintenant les collèges aurait un peu
plus d'autonomie avec cette réforme
alors la question de l'autonomie c'est
le renvoi au local des arbitrages que on
n'arrive pas à faire au niveau national
c'est rien de plus c'est à dire ça c'est
pas une bonne chose
ben c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un moment
on demande aux locales de réaliser la
quadrature du cercle
donc ça changerait rien vous récupérez
le problème sans en avoir pour autant
les solutions de n'avoir ni les
solutions et les moyens l'intersyndicale
a demandé pour finir sur cette réforme
du collège aux enseignants de boycotter
ces formations qui sont organisées
depuis la toussaint pour accompagner la
réforme ça va se poursuivre une fois les
côtés c'est les collègues qui vont
décider site par site de ce qu'ils vont
faire et c'est le cas le suivi le
service et comme souvent c'est à dire
que c'est très variable d'un endroit à
un autre ça dépend aussi parce que quand
j'ai évoqué la difficulté de mise en
oeuvre elle est effectivement beaucoup
plus difficile à certains endroits qu'à
d'autres et donc en fonction du contexte
la mobilisation est plus ou moins forte
qu est ce qui fait que c'est plus ou
moins compliquées bas parce que en fait
quand vous mettez en place ces
enseignements interdisciplinaire vous le
faites avec les personnels qui sont là
vous n'avez pas de moyens
supplémentaires donc en fonction des
ressources locales et de la possibilité
d'aménager les différents horaires des
uns et des autres la mise en oeuvre est
beaucoup plus facile à faire et plus
facile est faisable à certains endroits
et à d'autres endroits ça vrai casse
tête peut-être un dernier mot à la suite
de cette mobilisation justement m'a
écouté j'ai l'impression que mes
collègues du second degré n'ont pas
l'air décidé à lâcher la faire et je
pense qu'ils ont raison
et en ce qui concerne les revendications
salariales notamment va écouter nous
sommes engagés dans une négociation dit
ppr
la mobilisation de mardi était
l'occasion de peser de d'exprimer notre
mécontentement on attend les réponses du
ministère et on verra après si vous avez
le sentiment justin pour conclure
d'avoir été bien entendu parce que les
taxis aussi se sont beaucoup exprimés se
sont fait entendre
ils continuent leur mouvement ça n'a pas
noyé la revendication des enseignants
je pense pas parce que c'est une
revendication qui est transversal à
toute la fonction publique depuis
plusieurs années et elle est régulière
elle se manifeste régulièrement et
personne ne lâche la faire même si les
taxis se sont fait plus entendre que
vous bat les taxis ont peut-être des
modalités d'expression qui n'avait pas
brûlé à ses pneus peut-être peut-être
c'est fait et c'est peut-être ça oui
merci bertrand mesure secrétaire
départemental fsu
ces nuits pp donc dans les yvelines
merci à vous ce sont à présent les
jeunes qui s'expriment sur l'actualité
locale et nationale comme ont-ils perçu
les informations de ces derniers jours
c'est qu'en se préparer par william elle
avec camille lambert et les élèves du
collège des soldes billancourt
personnellement je trouve ça y'est dufau
déjà parce que bon je vois pas l'intérêt
encore là on est jeune donc l'école et
tous ces
et pas pour nous confie le genre les
gens qui en boivent je vous comprends
pas je pense plutôt qu'ils font ça
surtout pour se donner un style entre
parenthèses mais j'imagine que dans le
monde il ya des jeunes qui boivent en
secret avec son collège à mon avis ça
existe sûrement des jeunes qui boivent
en secret chez eux quand leurs parents
sont pas là si on est ivre on peut avoir
beaucoup de problèmes si on consomme
trop on peut faire des crises assez
grave
ou alors si jamais quels sont ils sont
en âge de conduire ça peut forcément
créer des accidents ou même les rendre
conscients enfin surtout chez des jeunes
kouassi fsa pas gérer ça ça peut vite
tourner au vinaigre
imaginons qu'un jeune et tu ne vois curé
qui les bus et qu'ils auraient tous ses
copains allaient ramener pas en ça peut
avoir de graves conséquences
avant l'accident idéalement c'est
l'alcool on sort ça que va dire pour
faire des petites fêtes par exemple jean
nouvel an en 19 familles on n'en sort
pas énormément non plus jean charles du
champagne du vin mais voilà par contre
l'alcool du ce but comme ça parce que je
suis pas pour puisqu'on en a envie ok
mais après si c'est concerne hamas nous
présente dans les boîtes à musique
par exemple il faudrait permettront mois
l'alcool peu juste par la froide advair
grand maximum
la suite de ce journal c'est à présent
avec notre séquence réalisée depuis le
début du mois en partenariat avec
l'association betabondieu production un
reportage accessibles aux sourds et aux
malentendants à cette semaine simon au
lit elle nous invite à découvrir le
travail de l'association art partage de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines partage est
une association qui existe depuis 2002
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines et qui réunit à la fois et des
peintres et des sculpteurs donc qui
réside sur l'ensemble de la ville
nouvelle et nous nous sommes rassemblés
donc avec ce même désir de partager
c'est à dire que allah nous
nous ressentons donc une émotion
artistique dans la création que nous
avons envie de faire partager à ceux qui
viennent à nos expositions ou visiteur
est également donc aux personnes à qui
nous offrons des ateliers dans le cadre
du handicap notamment donc aux personnes
atteintes de la maladie d'alzheimer
nous avons un homme dans l'association
ludovic postel donc donc vous voyez les
tableaux ici donc qui est un peintre de
la couleur et de la matière comme nous
avons donc un sculpteur marie-jeanne
carpier les statuts les sculptures
qu'elle a exposés ici sont des
sculptures donc en schiste marbre noir
et auparavant elle a travaillé aussi
bien sur la terre et le bronze
la qui a un style plus épuré un peu
moins dans la couleur un peu plus dans
des tons plus sombre et verena von
lichtenberg qui travaille plutôt le noir
et blanc avec un peu un petit peu de
couleurs
c'est important d'exposer à l'endroit où
mon crime donc à 50 et en yvelines de
rencontrer les personnes de saint
quentin en yvelines
et puis on trouve que la salle
d'exposition est magnifique donc avec
ses murs blancs ses seuls noirs son
éclairage on est vraiment très heureux
d'exposer ici et nous avons été
extrêmement bien accueilli
une nouvelle fois à simon oliel et la
bête à bon dieu production pour ses
reportages accessibles aux sourds et aux
malentendants réalisé tout au long du
mois de janvier
un mot du programme de nos confrères de
radio sensations nos confrères qui vous
propose ce week end un hebdo politique
avec et grégory gare et astier le maire
les républicains ne mord pas il évoquera
l'avenir de sa commune dans le nouvo st
quentin en yvelines
il reviendra aussi sur ce conflit qui
perdure avec l'opposition socialiste
autour de leur absence de l'exécutif
écouter cet extrait et c'est tout
l'enjeu est aussi de la stratégie
commerciale
moi j'ai siégé avec mon équipe le 9
janvier dernier au conseil
d'installation et je viens tout juste de
recevoir recommandé pour la première
fois de ma vie d'un du tribunal
administratif puisque la gauche conteste
l'élection du président des vice
présidents des conseils communautaires
et de tous les organismes dans lequel
vrai sujet c'est la première fois de ma
vie que je reçois un courrier du
tribunal
alors s'ils voulaient vraiment faire
partie de l'exécutif je crois que c'est
mal barré excusez moi le terme parce que
on peut discuter on est des adultes on
vous appelez je voulais mourir aurait
avoué à la réouverture du dialogue entre
les élus de la mairie qui a toujours été
ouvert c'est eux qui ont rompu le
dialogue l'actualité locale qui revient
lundi en direct à 18h sur notre antenne
première diffusion et puis ensuite à 18
à 19 heures pardon est aussitôt en
replay sur le www.tsys.com 18 points
comme voici quelques-uns des sujets que
nous allons développer l'élection à la
présidence des républicains dans les
yvelines tout d'abord valérie pécresse
qui a décidé de quitter ce poste
également en plus de celui de la
députation david douillet est donc le
seul candidat il va recevoir le soutien
des militants normalement dimanche lors
d'un vote interne elle sophie primas
sénatrice des yvelines devrait prendre
le poste de secrétaire départemental et
puis et mercredi 3 février édition
spéciale du journal avec le préfet des
yvelines qui nous accompagnera pendant
une demi-heure nous parlerons du bilan
de l'année 2015 mais aussi de sécurité
avec elle la probable prolongation dans
les prochains jours est de l'état
d'urgence en france c'est la fin de
cette édition un très bon week-end sur
notre antenne je vous retrouve samedi et
dimanche dès 19h30 pour un nouveau café
politique avec othman nassr où cette
fois ci est conseiller régional l'est
républicain en ile-de-france chef de
file de l'opposition à trappes
vous